hey youtubers is Charlie so Walking Dead
episode 6 so many things to talk about
we have negan they cast negan on the
show we may have gotten a little bit of
tease about what's going on with Glenn
and Abraham is suddenly a poet that
everybody wants to get with just give up
or spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet in the new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a $20
Amazon gift card starting with a
freaking huge stuff first number 5 who
is Dwight Dwight in the comics is part
of the Savior's so I think this mystery
group that Daryl ran into are actually
the Savior's they cast negan so it makes
sense that they're gonna start teasing
that out but based on the timing of the
casting like when they announced it I
don't think we're gonna actually see the
actor negan Jeffrey Dean Morgan show up
on screen like full blown show up on
screen till late in the season first off
we just have to say what the hell you
know why would they announce negan if
it's such a big deal wouldn't they tease
that out well I think they wanted to
make a little bit of noise just to get
people excited and the actor was gonna
be walking around set and they knew
Jeffrey Dean Morgan wouldn't come on the
show if he was gonna be a big character
so like why don't we just go ahead and
announce it whatever but essentially I
feel like Dwight's presence in the
episode the fact that he was a comic
book character was intended to tip the
hat to the Savior's because I guess you
could have assumed that this other group
might have been wolves but they just
seemed way too organized so they just
want it to be clear that this is not the
wolves it's a completely new group of
people that I think is the Savior's on
the number 4 WTF people will trade
anything for safety so when they're
confronted by this other group one of
the women says we're done kneeling they
trade back and forth you know the rules
your roles are [ __ ]
so just hammering home the idea that
they're super organized and I love the
fact that the dude that gets bit just
immediately on the spot is like just
take it take it and after his friend
chops his arm off he does the nice thing
and takes the watch off the severed arm
and hands it back to the dude like here
you're gonna you're gonna need this
there were so many casual walkers in
this episode that turned into like
really funny moments like you have
Abraham trying to get that rocket
launcher that was hilarious then you
have Daryl with the motorcycle helmet
Walker which is still alive by the way
despite the fact that it looks like
there's almost nothing left like it's
just a head in a motorcycle helmet so if
you ever wondered how far walkers can
decay
still be walkers like still be moving
around and bite people they can get at
least this far and what about the
walkers that were encased in glass
sleeping beauty walkers that was so
awesome
part of me wonders if the writers wanted
to get really sympathetic by making that
girl at diabetic and then killing her
off so they wouldn't have to deal with
her in future stories like well she's
gonna have to get insulin from somewhere
so it's gonna be a liability two stories
there was gonna have to be searching for
more insulin so why don't we just use
her as bait in this episode on a my
number three WTF Abraham vs. Sasha so it
admittedly they're on the same team but
Sasha keeps having to remind him not to
create more breadcrumbs for other people
to follow than necessary like how come
you got to go kill all those random
walkers Abraham is in complete
Terminator mode but he's totally self
aware that he's crazy which is why I
like it it's not crazy like the wolf
Morgan is keeping locked up he doesn't
think that he's crazy he thinks that
he's right anytime a person wonders that
they're crazy they're probably not
insane insane people don't wonder if
they're insane but who else flipped a
little bit when Abraham found the
jackpot like it's almost like he's
seeing exactly what he wants to see he
finds a bunch of rockets of rocket
launcher a bunch of cigars it's like
okay is this a trap or something I don't
understand on a my number two WTF
Abraham explains his end game so this is
actually where the episode gets really
awesome this is probably one of the best
Abraham episodes ever he's now the
slightly crazy self-aware warrior poet
of The Walking Dead and he knows what he
wants he knows his end game better than
Rick does at this point an end game for
him
is Sasha although admittedly I think he
just kind of twisted that at the end
he's probably been physically attracted
to her for a little while just just like
a normal dude would there's nothing
special about that it's their time
together like recognizing and calling
each other on their craziness that he is
really really attracted to that's what
hooks him and makes him want to get to
know her really really better in his own
words and the really cool way that the
writers played this is that Sasha kind
of leans into it like you think that's
something that I might even want you
know she's just teasing him a little bit
like okay you know like I might be down
for that but as Abraham says she calls
him on his [ __ ] and is like you you
definitely have some stuff to work on
before we get to that endgame stuff
you're talking about this is a moment
that most of the other characters
haven't had yet
so like Abraham's character
is this like a couple steps ahead of a
lot other characters like Carol Daryl
Rick move in check to check as Abraham
says it like if there was ever a scene
that you guys should go back and
re-watch it's Abraham's speech at the
end he's such a poet
it's so awesome high fives to Michael
Cudlitz you won this episode but on my
number one WTF though biggest casualty
of the episode is the motorcycle you
just see Gerald look at him is they
right off you are gonna be sorry
best bet The Walking Dead isn't gonna
spend tens of thousands of dollars
creating that custom bike without
letting Daryl try to get it back but we
will see the Savior's eventually we'll
see that bike
best bet he's gonna get it back I really
feel like they wanted Daryl's character
arc in this episode to mirror Abraham's
character arc but I feel like the
writers did a better job with Abraham it
was a little more clear Daryl's always a
bit more of an ambiguous character like
he finds the fuel truck so it kind of
ends on a high moment he finds Abraham
and Sasha you should be happy but then
you get the help at the end like what's
that copy this is why everybody if you
were confused why everybody is talking
about Clem
because the voice sounded more like
Glenn than it sounded like Rick like you
would naturally assume that it's Rick
like there radioing back to the safe so
and try and find out what's going on but
that's the open channel that everyone
was using back a couple episodes ago so
anybody with a walkie-talkie could radio
in and say help at this point I feel
like it is foolish to assume the Klan is
dead I think he's definitely alive
they're keeping him off the opening
credits just as a ruse just so people
think that he's dead so it's a big WTF
when he comes back no idea when he will
come back though but let me know here's
my big question for you guys who do you
think said help at the end of the
episode was that Glenn or was that Rick
the episode itself was great I feel like
there wasn't as much action as some of
the previous episodes like especially
when the Wolves attacked the SafeZone
but you have to remember they're
building towards the mid-season finale
that's always like the point of
explosion so I feel like the tension in
this episode in the things that they
tease were really well-placed but you
want there to be a slow progression so
like last week was kind of a Down
episode it was kind of like a season two
Hershel's farm episode then it got a
little bit crazier in this episode
started teasing the Savior's this other
big group of organized people leading up
to next week and then the mid-season
finale when we'll probably see some
really big savior stuff don't forget
those say
is just like one stop along the way
there's a couple of their big comic book
things they're doing this season but
they are doing more things from the
comic book so just expect more people
like Dwight like more minor comic book
characters to start popping up in
addition to really big ones like negan
of course here's kind of what I'm
expecting from the negan front I think
they'll tease the Savior's first like
they did in this episode we'll learn a
little bit more about them we'll see a
couple ancillary figures then we'll
actually see where they come from then
they'll start talking about their leader
then eventually the emperor will appear
speak of the devil and he shall appear
until his name is said out loud I don't
think we're gonna see him if you guys
didn't see they also dropped the season
premiere of into the badlands I'm
probably not gonna do videos for that
but it is actually look like a pretty
cool show think samurais in the Wild
West so like a bunch of Michonne's
walking around chopping people in half
but congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Josh Mackin you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info
well guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my Walking Dead
Season 6 playlist in case you need to
catch up and you can click here for the
flash trailer just post it marilla Brod
is coming this week is gonna be so
awesome thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight